this is Startalk this is Startalk radio
welcome to the first installment in a
series of special edition cosmic queries
that we have dubbed make America smart
again I'm your host and personal
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson and
joining me today is my co-host is
someone who is no stranger to star talk
radio
professional comedian Chuck nice job hey
know how I like I like the fact you put
professional on the end of this are very
very kind of it might be the first time
I've done that as that will finally pay
your rent or income really clearly I am
up paying my mortgage from comedy now
somehow you got that infrared very
pleased to hear that today we're talking
about immigration policy specifically
the contributions that immigrants and
descendants of immigrants have made to
science technology engineering and math
in this country now you know I'm not
going to do that alone I'd hardly do any
of this alone so to help us out we
brought in special guest the one the
only for Reid Zakaria
yeah animation point that's right you do
you have an exclamation point like born
with your name well I was deserved one I
was hoping to be called professional
something or I guess I'm just Fareed
Zakaria I feel like I'm a professional
but okay something for the next for the
next 40 minutes for our professional I
enough so a freed is an Indian American
journalist and author and he's also host
of CNN's Fareed Zakaria GPS right I
assume that my fan I like the the the
you know the Ankur yes we gotta go
that's something that deserves to be
said in stereo so you good Rick gbes
yeah also writes a weekly column for The
Washington Post
so for read thanks for joining us and
we've been friends for a while so I
didn't just pick you up off mystery yeah
right right right so so I I did some
homework on you and you have an
extraordinary academic pedigree to be
doing what you do
so many pundits out there they're kind
of self-made they're you know they did a
little bit of their own reading and they
they have strong opinions and people
love hearing you know vociferously
voiced opinions and you always have this
sort of calm voice and you have all this
academic substrate there so it always
the case though it always a guy who has
an extensive and impressive academic
pedigree you don't have to screen your
dreams other guys that are just like
okay so you feel that way hunters will
help tip for you like those are the guys
always the guy who doesn't know anything
that's just like I'm told you now this
is the way it is like yeah I think of
myself as a lapsed academic maybe a
little bit like you I don't know if you
can still consider yourself a practicing
in my mind I am whether or not in
practice I management profession would
regard you as such as if I look for
tonight give all this up and just go
back to the lab and then you'll never
find me again so I want to just explore
this I what I bring to the table for you
to react to is the fact that science in
the United States which really came of
age in the 20th century with the there
are many drivers but let's take for
example the formation of the National
Science Foundation but there were
earlier indications go back to Abraham
Lincoln who in 1963 when he clearly had
other priorities he signed into law that
created the National Academy of Sciences
recognizing what role science was
playing in Europe and how important it
was saying that we get me some of that
for our country and he also created the
land-grant College System so he had
tremendous foresight into the role of
Science and Technology as a fundamental
driver of everything the United States
would become so now I look at I'm closer
to physics than I am
biology of course so I look at things
like the Manhattan Project so crucial to
what became 20th century politics and
science and it landed us where we became
where we were for the entire second half
of the 20th century and most of those
scientists were foreign-born nationals
and and so wit wit from Europe from your
worldview how could you just explain how
this works just you know it's
fascinating you're absolutely right to
focus on the beginnings because we think
that America was always the most
scientifically innovative country in the
world you know we look at the Nobel
Prizes and we take it for granted 5% of
the world's population we get about 75%
of the world's prizes and that doesn't
even count Obama's Peace Prize which I
regard as kind of a weird one - first
year office one it's like a Lifetime
Achievement Award at age 25 25 well you
didn't really earn this but we got to
give it to you just because we like
exactly but if you look at the early
20th century 1910 1914 I'd forget the
exact date Germany had won more prizes
in science Nobel Prize and science then
Britain and the United States put
together so the u.s. becomes a
powerhouse in science basically for
three big reasons the first is the
destruction of Europe basically world
war one world war two Great Depression
the place gets flattened all the
universities shall be the last man
standing with the last man standing and
particularly Germany gets destroyed if
Germany was the scientific superpower
second we take in all these immigrants
people forget even in the 30s with all
the restrictions a hundred thousand Jews
came in from Europe many of them
scientists as you say many of them
worked on the Manhattan Project after
that of course the door opens even wider
and the third is massive government
funding so let's think about it Europe
been destroyed any more government
funding is down to half what it used to
be our only hope frankly is that we keep
taking in the best and brightest in the
world otherwise you already see the
world catching up
you already see that you know Japanese
scientists win Nobel Prizes routinely
that you now have the Chinese getting in
on the action so we have to recognize
hearing there we're five percent of the
world we want to make sure that we're
not winning just five percent of the
Nobel prizes Wow
that well that's that's that that very
fact then is enabled only if you then
not only have access to but mutual
interest in coming to the world's
greatest talent and the world's greatest
talent isn't always in your country
because everybody's human and innovation
is not
but he has a monopoly on innovation it's
just a matter of opportunity to express
it and and you know what I noticed
something new if you probably know I was
for a while a trustee of the college I
went to Yale
and there was a lot there are a lot of
government from there you see the way he
did that but listen there before you
know what I like about the way the
foreach is did I dropped anyways he was
like a it was like a subject night I
mean wall college in your head no like a
little afterthought you know right and
the color said I went to Yale yeah so
here's the point
Yale is private of course a lot of
government cuts to public university
some of the great public universities in
America and we noticed that we were had
access to better and better scientists
who were well very favorite what biggest
University of Arizona is cutting funding
in Michigan State is cutting funding so
Berkeley you know now but I actually
have been blessed Berkeley than anywhere
else but what I was struck by me being
in New York or being in the world that
you and I are and Neil I thought we
wouldn't have to offer these guys more
money no the scientists only cared about
what they have good labs and good
colleagues right because they wanted to
be around other smart scientists they
wanted to be able to have graduate
students who are good so it makes me I
mean the point you're making people will
come to where other smart people are
that's the magnet that attracts you you
know what's funny is that what you just
said is just a fact of human nature when
you want to do well when you want to win
when you want to be the best then your
own personal gain tends to take a
backseat to the accomplishment of a
greater goal for instance sports stars
will take a salary cut
so that really good players can stay on
their team or they'll give up being the
number one guy on a team to go beat in a
team effort where they're pretty much
guaranteed a championship this is part
of the way we think so I'm going to tell
your agent that you voluntarily agreed
to take a pay cut it should be at the
right comedy club so things are going to
have to happen one you don't have to
tell my agent to get me paid first and
then you can tell them I'm willing to
take that big card
so freed I hadn't fully that was like a
missing piece of my total worldview of
this that it's not just simply come here
because you're being persecuted there
it's come here because there are other
really smart people here and then the
the resonance of this intellectual
community will not only benefit you but
will benefit all of science and any good
scientist is will tell you I want to see
science grow even if I'm not part of it
because there's a curiosity that we all
carry to this frontier and whoever can
move it that's great
exactly I mean you find that one of the
things that Chinese were having
difficulty they've been trying to
recruit back some of the best and
brightest have we trained here reach
that the United States trained here and
they will find they would say to them
we'll build you the biggest lab we'll
give you unlimited research funds what
the a lot of Chinese professors were
saying is we don't have the best
graduate students we want to work with
the best graduate students and those
people are at Berkeley or Harvard or now
let's change now Beijing University and
Chang one in particular have superb
graduate students and so that you're
beginning to see all many of the best
and brightest go back to China so when I
go back to again the Manhattan Project I
go back to the Apollo project each of
those had sort of military motivations I
mean we don't like remembering Apollo as
military but NASA was in response of
course to Sputnik and the threat that
that that we perceived by that but you
look at you look at there was of course
Einstein came over like you said this
whole flux of Jewish scientists then
after the Second World War we build our
space program on the back of Wernher von
Braun for example and now you have all
these people Enrico Fermi about labs
named after this guy Fermilab's
okay he's Italian his wife is Jewish and
all of this is going on this is America
that's exactly right it's not even being
fine-tooth picked for for what that is
it's just of course and and of course to
just emphasize one piece of this massive
government funding people don't like to
point this out when you talk about the
all governments
is bad you know then you say oh the
government shouldn't pick winners or
losers so look at the microchip industry
that the beating heart of the computer
revolution is the microchip right Texas
Instruments in basically invents it and
then the US government through the the
Air Force buys something like 60 to 70%
of all microchips produced the cost
initially is 1,000 per microchip it goes
down to $30 per microchip because the
government keeps buying it you know it
basically allows for scale which then
drops the price exactly the same thing
the people that people are trying to do
in the solar industry or the wind
industry are the people in the
government who are doing this they have
this foresight are you telling me this
we have normally actually that much
credit to government officials I think
we have if you look at DARPA which is
the agency in the Defense Department
that does this this actually recently
interviewed another DARPA
we are talk it was really good fence
advanced projects research agency agency
and then and it there was a ARPANET
which is the precursor that the internet
was in fact you know came up the Defense
Department effect invents it GPS eyes is
as part of the Defense Department right
I think I think that the main thing we
have to realize is you have to throw a
lot of resources at the science is
expensive basic research is the most
important but you also need the
development of technologies of course
you're going to miss a lot of course
some companies like Solyndra will go
bankrupt but you know if you think about
it the same time the government made a
loan to Solyndra for about six hundred
million dollars
it made a loan to Tesla for 600 million
dollars now what happened Solyndra went
bankrupt Tesla has got has gone up first
10,000 percent right guess who made all
that money the private sector the
shareholders and ms Elon Musk so when
the government loses the money we the
taxpayers take the blame but we don't
get the upside that's just the nature of
it but it doesn't mean that it doesn't
work for us would you get the upside in
the sense that if the government births
an industry in the industry has tax base
that comes back to the government
exactly
and then each scientific invention
produces and known at what price you
know yes and just for the record star
talk was birthed by the government
on a National Science Foundation grant
they believe that in what we were trying
to do that so that was a little more
like the Solyndra one yeah so I thought
we were doing okay I don't know you know
you go I just I'm looking our notes for
this that apparently you know of course
Benjamin Franklin let's go back to him
when are the first great scientists of
the United States he I mean I
he will books on research and
electricity so he's Polly he might even
be been a better scientist and founding
father I mean if you look at him what
his record is and what he salutes
covered in a the books that he had
published but regardless he he his
parents fled England because of
religious persecution and he's here and
so he's basically an immigrant his
immigrant lineage which would be an easy
back then again it's pretty good that
see it the thing is though doesn't
really count when you you're not brown
oh that's that anything like just word
let's get to that they're all that
they're a rule let's get to this so we
have these I could decide all the famous
scientists of the 20th century that
shaped modern you know we have Wernher
von Braun from Germany who burst the he
he basically designed the Saturn 5
rocket to goddess to the moon because he
had that knowledge and and and awareness
from his from developing the v2 rocket
and that's basically the first ballistic
missile and left Earth's atmosphere
found his target fell on the target
right that's that's a ballistic missile
v2 being the Rockets that the Germans
developed and and written and rained on
London in 1940 correct correct all the
rain would be a little too delicate a
word for what these things did it
so they they fall out of this guy's
supersonically see it's not it it's not
like
not a whistle no you do not just you're
walking and then the block explodes okay
that's how that my dad was a graduate
student in London in 1945 and was having
coffee with a bunch of his friends in a
cafe he was and they said him stay for a
while he said no I got to get back I got
to get some work done he walks out and
he turns his back and v2 rocket hit the
cafe everyone there every friend of his
died if he had just stayed when they
told him just have one more cup of
coffee he would have been dead
yeah then we wouldn't eat me ham is
really having this conversation right no
I think of it the other way that's how
many others might I've been having
conversation not him I am great I would
have had to tackle eight and any of it
and you ever use that as a motivator
fashion the factor to get you to do your
work let me tell you something I would
go yeah you know what I got back to work
and I'm alive no different we will a
different my dad's had we had a tough
upbringing user self self-made man and
he always said I went through stuff I
don't want you to have to go through
with his attitude let me just complete
this list Steve Jobs as we know he is
his family lineage is traceable Syria
for I remember this is actual father was
there was a Syrian immigrants Emory and
Elon Musk a South African but via
Internet and Sergey Brin Google is in
Google right all of this all of this and
so so not to mention all the real I mean
the scientist these are all we're
talking we're trying to the entrepreneur
right we're just on with the entre NORs
if you register now find this devil's
advocate this is a list of people any
country would want so do you say yes you
can immigrate if you have these kinds of
ambitions or if you're going to if
you're going to well we'll let you in if
you go get a degree in engineering I
mean is that is that the devil's
advocate posture here that has not yet
been resolved in this conversation so
there's no question we should take any
of those kinds of people I mean there's
I think Michael Bloomberg had the idea
if you get a PhD and in science you
should have a green card
stapled to your degree when you get it
that makes a lot of sense sense there's
no question which is also also Newt
Gingrich with a very very strong posture
on that and I and I think that you know
that seems to me a no brain
one of the parts of immigration reform
one hopes eventually we'll get to the
harder question as you says we take in
lots of people who are not like that
that's called a family unification
policy I think we probably take in too
many that way into few who are skilled
and brain-based
but you know there's also something to
be said for the sheer drive that that
low-skill immigrants bring obviously in
the right numbers and in a way that can
they can be integrated but the biggest
problem for rich country is you lose
that drive you lose that hunger I mean
you know we all have children and the
more fortunate the parent circumstance
that kids are going to be great for and
lazy sake and hey can have the same
Drive right right but my night Arab
Emirates has a similar problem it's a
very wealthy country but who's going to
clean the laundry and I was going to but
but some guy who comes from you know
Mexico or Guatemala hunger induce who's
willing to risk everything abandoned you
know home culture come there come here
to wash dishes just to explain hours a
day that's a good surrender Drive and
energy and by the way that person might
end up doing something remarkable his
children that end up doing something
remelting you have to keep in the mind
is the children of those people tend to
be the ones who had that same Drive but
they are also educated here in America
which gives them a distinct advantage
when it comes to a bigger Drive than
American with the same American
education it goes so they're out older
and what we're doing is we're creating
better Americans let's do it we got to
go to break when we come back more of
our conversation on a special edition of
cosmic queries let's make America smart
again with my special guest for read
Zakaria when we come back
welcome back to star talk radio we've
been talking about the impact of
immigration on science and technology in
America and we've got Chuck nice to help
me out here sir deep thinking dude yeah
you know it's all good comics art by the
way this is true I was going to say I
try to keep that I try to lower
expectations as much as possible Neal
how that works and we've got our
in-studio guest journalist author and
longtime actual friend of mine to read
Zakaria Fareed the great to have you on
the show I just want to just get back in
just real quickly so so would you so
when when if there's a policy that says
we'll stop all immigration evaluated and
say okay here is the proscenium through
which you'll walk if we judge that you
will be the right person for this is
there risk of that abuse with that kind
of happened 100 years ago didn't it
listen Northern Europeans not the
southern Europeans there's a lot of
judgment being placed on who was worthy
and who was not I think the big danger
is that we think we can fit we can
identify talent and drive and ambition
and creativity and those are complicated
things so yes we should do more
skill-based we should probably do a
little bit less family unification we
should get the balance right we should
it'll be the immediate family you mean
extend it exactly you can basically and
we were told but by the way I mean again
in the old days in the 19th century one
person from a village in Sicily would
come and then bring the whole village
leader here right right row it's we have
we have done that and we've managed to
absorb it and that is partly what is
given this country the kind of diversity
and and and richness it has but you know
in terms of balancing the numbers maybe
more skill-based maybe less of this as
you say extended family unification but
I really think it's important to
remember we don't know when we take in a
ten year old kid what that kid is going
to be whether they may he or she may be
a poor Guatemalan that doesn't mean that
you know talent is sprinkled evenly
throughout the planet and you might be
getting amazing people even though they
look like they're poor peasants from you
know places that are not doing well in
the world so one other question to the
queries where's your solicitor these
from we have a queries from all over the
internet and so
Encarnacion where you can find Startalk
so for read that there's the flipside of
its that no one in America talks about
if we are so great that everyone wants
to come to us that's a brain drain for
other countries we're getting the best
of other countries sort of druids
sucking their intellectual capital into
our borders if we get a stronger world
will be less capable to do that even if
we want it to so the way I think about
this Niall it's a very good question as
you can imagine we haven't grown up in
India and come here I would hear this
often people would say why are you
leaving India you know that your country
needs you
but here's the truth I actually do think
talent is sprinkled throughout there are
millions and millions of talented
Indians I'm not that special that what's
special is the environment that this
country has created we're smart and
talented people can flourish there's
another way of putting this there was a
member of parliament an opposition
member of parliament to stir up one day
the indian parliament and after then
Prime Minister Indira Gandhi he said
madam Prime Minister can you explain to
me one question I noticed when I look
around the world Indians seem to do
really well everywhere except in India
what does that tell you about how you
run this country all right yeah there's
no answer there's no good it's all about
creating an ecosystem where talent can
flourish it's the problem in India or
China or Africa is not that there aren't
talented people if you haven't created
the ecosystem that lets some fun about
the Einstein project in in Africa and
looking for the next Einstein black
Einstein basically oh really oh yeah
yeah it's in Africa and Africa right
it's very cool I have no doubt in my
mind that there is somebody as talented
with you know in terms of raw
intelligence he or she exists yeah the
question is can you create the ecosystem
that led Einstein do what he did in
Germany and and very large atomic they
never see this is Einstein playing
basketball right right and it's an
Einstein had a promising career as a
basketball player until an ankle injury
to the book in a book so what do you
have Chuck oh we got our cosmic queries
so let's just jump right into it since
we already set up the fact of where we
get these the first one that we always
take is from a patreon patron because
they support us financially and I'm
going to put them to the top of Lisbon
right at the top of the list they paid
they go right to the top of the list
kind of like not even ashamed to say
well I'm not okay like Congress and
lobbying okay now you get lobbyists for
the show
you've got their lobbyists for the seat
give me 328 porters you're all lobbyists
a drain the swamp let's yeah let's just
hear from the free lotion in the galaxy
we're going to drain the galaxy all
right here we go here's our first from
Renee Douglas and says Renee's from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania says why is it
important to you that the United States
lead the world in science she's speaking
with you directly Neal hmm are you just
rooting for your own team so to speak or
is there a better reason so what she is
and the reason I picked that as first
question is because we just finished
talking about the fact that there's a
brain drain on other righty-right so it
fits perfectly into that so okay what is
wrong with uh with in other countries I
mean are we just do we just root for
America or is it possible that if we
were to spread the wealth a little bit
maybe science would flourish even more
maybe we would see even greater you say
if you added all the rags I always but I
always add everything to these people's
questions because I'm like I want you to
get a little more deeply I got a little
bit I put it I got I got you so so I
think it's natural to root for the home
team yeah and you don't to do that to
the point of waging war I think that's
my opinion in that regard but you move
for the home team and I grew up in the
United States in the second half of the
20th century cat which had a lot of
problems of its own you know a hot war
cold war civil rights movement campus
unrest but in there we were going to the
moon and we all knew that that required
innovations in science and technology
we knew this and so I would be upset if
that that sense of inventing a future
were no longer happening on the soil in
which I was born I would be upset
however I'd be even more upset if it
didn't happen anywhere else in the world
right so yeah I wanted to have been the
one who discovered the Higgs boson in a
Texas super collider
got its budget cut in 1993 having judged
well what's the value of this because I
my view is piece had just broken out in
1989 and when piece breaks out who needs
physicists as far as anybody thinks so
the Higgs boson gets discovered in in
the Large Hadron Collider in Switzerland
at European collaboration we're part of
that collaboration but we're not the
leader not the major leader not a
quarterback right without the
quarterback on the team on the team
we're on the team with oh that is very
unamerican to not be the quarterback you
know we supposed to be the quarter that
were supposed to be the quarterback so
as a scientist were all delighted but as
an American all right so that's just I'm
just being honest with my feelings there
but if it has long as it happens
somewhere if the whole world closed down
then we're all moving back into the cave
decades but by the way it does matter to
American economics you know basically
the way you get economic growth is two
things how many people do you have and
how much productivity do you have in
other words it's the number of people
who in the work force labor and its
productivity what what is how productive
ie is each of their each of those people
and productivity arises only through
technology technological innovation in
science yes exactly
just to be clear you can the this is a
slightly controversial statement but I
want to be very frank about it
the times when the arts grows
economically in almost every case I've
seen it's because they have been touched
by technology and so as it enables it to
occur and I think there's also a way and
there's a mutually reinforcing thing the
arts feed creativity which allows free
Mendozas wonderful stories about
Einstein when he would get stuck on a
physics problem which stop and you go
and start playing his violin he said
that it would unlock something in his
head in his mind that he couldn't
understand so ideally you have a kind of
you know into symbiosis and creativity
right right well I'm just going to add
all that Rene you've heard for Reed and
Neil us and they were very very
diplomatic I'm going to say yeah I
wanted to be here in America because I
live here and this is my country and
it's like inviting somebody to your
house one guy you could just have live
with you the other guy says
you know what I'm gonna build an
addition and that's a guy I want to live
with a man I love this Chrissy Borden
says this what does the scientific
community think or hope is the next big
discovery on the horizon
that would be really wonderful if it
happened here in the United States gosh
there's so many things happening that
are extraordinary I mean I think that if
you look at some of the most dramatic
new frontiers I think are in biology so
you might my eight-year-old daughter is
here because she's a huge fan of Neil's
she's sitting outside in curry school I
might have she's cutting school for this
discounters school counselor school
after school all right well she was
talking about the brain episode that she
was watching about that Neil did one
Nova ScienceNOW no sorry sir and if you
think about how mapping the brain is
going to transform our understanding of
the brain what happens you know from
medicine and just to knowledge David via
this is actually in a weird way it's
uncharted territory oh yeah John's
beginning to wonder the frontiers are
just that well then you have Harry but
but even more exciting you marry it to
the revolution in Big Data where the
brain is going to produce the volume of
data is going to be so large there's
only the new super computer brain
invented big data yes it is exactly so
it seems to me that's the one but
there's so many I mean Isaac's yeah yeah
I agree for III the brain so
neuroscience as a frontier also of
course AI yes is related related can
will we have autonomous robots they can
think for themselves without having to
just solve a problem that you hand it so
that's a their own problem I'm well you
saw this problem solver John Day himself
self-determining I'm sentient now Neil
they now say that AI is getting good
enough that computers can do many of the
things that you means to do having
computers go do editing trailers of
movies so my question is when do you
think you can get a computer who could
tell better jokes than you you nothing
with that sauce not going to happen no
let me tell you what's working on that
it's one of the uniquely mystery unique
mysteries of the world for eaglet and
I'm going to keep it that way
wouldn't it be sad if all kinds of
people went out of work but that you
maintained yeah okay that's the one
thing computers can do is make us laugh
I don't know only profession left I
don't see any sadness in that at all
my favorite computer joke ever this one
can told me this I think was controlled
by him it was a robot you know wandering
a party I think there was a human
somewhere with it but I pretended it
wasn't so they said well I asked where
did you learn your your knowledge of the
world oh I went to solid state
university yeah I don't think that did
you have a PhD in physics together not
that one no knows a solid-state means
anymore it means no tubes no vacuums
right yeah no that's a solid state yes
all right you got let's go too
you know I got to do this meal because
I've seen quite a few of these questions
come across and so I'm reading Ben
Knuffle camps question as a
representative to for all of you who
have written this type of question not
only for this show but another show that
I co-hosted with Bill Nye on a similar
type of subject meal
why does Startalk have episodes that
either have nothing to do or vaguely
encompass astronomy physics or other
science if I want it liberal politics
you'll like this part for read but I
just turn on CNN okay so the reason I
the reason I read that question is
because this is not political what we
are talking about well we'll talk about
just the world as a better place
whatever and however you slice and dice
that politically right that's people's
own motives but there's some fundamental
reality that has to matter here before
that conversation even happens right but
but I can address that I can say I could
enter this world naively as a scientist
and think oh yeah sorry let's just do
science but but then you wake up and
realize that any science that happens is
embedded in a political system correct
I'm not an island right and I have to
beat much some of my colleagues over the
head
who cry foul when NASA spends money on
something they don't think they should
spend money on the space station or
on-demand program which has always been
a controversial passive
spending relative to pure research and I
go to my colleagues and I say you are
treating NASA as though it's your
private funding agency when it was born
in a cold war environment and there are
there are their geopolitical mission
statements that NASA fulfills and you
are not the only one in town that it
serves and in fact the science budget of
NASA historically has never been maxed
out at about 35% and the long-term
average is around 1/4 and all the rest
goes to Geo politically driven decisions
for what NASA does in this world and and
if you think about that you know the
point we were making earlier if if
American science of the reason we're the
forefront of global science is you know
the three things I talked about Europe
got destroyed to two world wars we took
in lots of immigrants and then we spend
lots of government money on it those are
political issues and so if you want to
create great science yes you have to
have great scientists but you've got to
figure out how do you get them how do
you create an environment where they
flourish how do the ideas get all of
that is embedded in a political system
that's got to recognize that in order to
make wise decisions right regarding it
going forward
that's all that's it's not more
complicated but the drivers of it are
simple and it's not more political than
that and by the way this used to be
totally bipartisan it was Eisenhower who
set the spending maxi Eisenhower
spending 3 percent of GDP on basic
science Reagan increased the spending it
is recently that we have gotten into a
situation where everything is political
it's uselessly blind Republican this
used to be bipartisan not only that of
course under President Nixon we formed
the Environmental Protection Agency
right and the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration NOAA 1 right
so you're right 3 when I look
historically there's a lot of
commingling of political platforms that
are in the service of science and
historically even the National Science
Foundation has been bipartisan although
the motives were little
you know so and many would complain at
the Rd spending on the regen a lot of
that went to Star Wars which which many
in my sights of a community objected to
but at the end of the day even if the
motors are different science gets done
so science is political but we are not
politicizing it so that that's the we're
not coming down on one side or another
we're coming down on the side of science
one could if there's a plea at the side
that doesn't like science if it's anti
sign you can tell you the consequences
of what it is to be a hard science
that's all we got to take a quick break
and we'll be back soon with Chuck nice
and my special guest today reads Acharya
welcome back to star talk radio cosmic
queries in a special installment called
make America smart again
I've got Fareed Zakaria as my special
guest and you know this man I mean he's
a he's a geopolitical genius and he's
got a special feature coming out on CNN
with a special it's a special primetime
documentary one-hour on the most
powerful man in the world President
United States who we say is Vladimir
Putin Oh throw down so I'm should love
that will make the case you judge okay
yeah you're sweet I'm going to hit one
thing just to bring some closure to it
when I was in graduate school
at least half of everyone in the
sciences and engineering were foreign
nationals and at that time they would
come get their PhDs their masters and
stay as the rest of the world rises up
and as America fades we become less of a
carrot for those very same graduate
students and I've seen many of them go
back to their home country to China to
India will there be a point when they
won't even come here as graduate
students because those fully trained
phd's now train their own graduate
students and then we have this reverse
flux of the intellectual capital of the
world it's a great question my own sense
is it will be a long time before that
happens because the one thing that the
United States still absolutely dominates
is higher education if you look at the
lists of the top 20 universities in the
world
18 are American top 50 in the world 36
or American and it's hard to design a
really superb world-class university
because there's a lot that goes into it
do that overnight you can't do that
overnight Harvard and Yale and Princeton
have huge advantages of 100 in the 17th
century yes you have lots of money they
contain a car endowment they can see you
did I tell you the roots I'll tell you
one piece of it that I wonder about when
you look at a place like China at the
heart of Western science has been the
ability to question authority for the
graduate student to tell the professor
you're full of it
you're raw your ideas are wrong I
remember
readings are outdated or I got a better
idea niels bohr used to begin his
lectures as great physicist uh from the
turn of the century used to begin his
lectures in copenhagen Litella students
I want you to I want to start by telling
you you must approach this lecture by
assuming everything that I say might be
untrue my beam might be falsifiable in
other words that sense of really being
willing to challenge authority that is
not yet true in in a place like China
and I wonder if there's a cultural
barrier which will mean that it takes
even longer for that day I've thought a
lot about this and accept I came to it
from a less noble angle and when I see
little children in malls
if there's a toddler just steps out of a
stroller and the parent says get back in
the truck now is an American kid it's
also something else that you talked
about we had a conversation long time
ago about the fact that in other
cultures you may not see the aspirations
to do things that we that we take for
granted in this culture that's when I
grow up I'm going to be an astronaut
right right what do you want to be when
you eat whatever I want to be when you
grow up in it and in other countries
unreachable goals are actually tamp down
right where's here so I always make that
cue go ahead right but I but I would do
want to emphasize it's important to
remember these are not god-given
advantages the United States has I can
lose them very easily if we don't create
maintain the culture of openness and
creativity why God shed His grace on me
what were you I do think that means when
they need to be a greater focus on
science you'll like this either one of
the my favorite lines from one of Tom
Friedman's books the New York Times
columnist it was in China and he was
noticing you know Bill Gates was
happened to be there and people were
going crazy over gates because he was
this computer whiz I mean yes he was
also very rich but the combination and
he said I guess I realized the
probability the difference between China
and India's in China
Bill Gates as Britney Spears in America
Britney Spears is British yeah we we
venerate pop icons they turned a geeky
computer scientist into pop icons it
looks you've done it again Fareed okay
don't give me another one here here we
go speaking with what free just said
here's Bob Longmire from Facebook who
says this
given the current political climate how
do you suggest we help advance
scientific literacy with people who view
science throw a negative political lens
very very good query what is your
solution here if I'm trying to get
people to understand what science is and
how and why it works and they're swept
up into a worldview that does not allow
that in that's what do you do in the
world of politics what has the world
done in the history of this exercise you
know it's very frustrating because it's
not just an assault on science it's an
assault on expertise it's an it's an
assault at some fundamental level on
knowledge and I think there's there is a
tendency to say that all this knowledge
is either biased or opinion 8 or you
have your facts I have my facts no you
can't have alternate facts you can you
can disagree you can draw your own
conclusions on the basis of those five
how much of that isn't fed it's fed by
the fact that in politics and in
religion people are there is there isn't
that absolute right or wrong and so
people are accustomed to arguing what
they want to be true now you've ads
science to the mix and they feel like
they can have the conversation in the
same way you know I think it's coming at
a populist moment where people think
that all the experts get everything
wrong
and I was reading the New York Times
recently there's an article about Steve
Bannon Donald Trump's chief strategist
who's having everybody read a book
called the best and the brightest this
is a book about how the smart Kennedy
advisors got America into Vietnam and
the the moral of the book is meant to be
or the way he'd sees it all these
experts were wrong with disastrously
answer to this in sac if you read the
book what's interesting is actually what
it points out is all the political
advisers were overconfident arrogant
they were not listening to the real
expertise of the historians the people
who understood Vietnam who understood
China cultures and cultures I it was
actually a story about expertise that
was ignored because people had a
political lens which was anti communism
which they filtered everything through
right Wow
Chuck what else you get all right let's
move on shall we to Anne
a cold way and and says love Startalk do
you foresee the future of international
collaborations changing as a result of
the new frankly barbaric policies that
have been put in place now that this is
maybe when this comes out this will have
changed but as of now there is still a
recording so-called as of this recording
there still a so-called immigration ban
that was in place and then a federal
judge said no and that's where we are at
this juncture well I'll make a statement
and I want for Reid to react okay
scientifically when we collaborate
internationally we do so at
international conferences they don't
happen to be in your department or in
your country your you can still
collaborate because you get to get there
we create these occasions and where
there's an intellectual discourse and
their workshops their international
conferences and the like you guys have
your own like science date it's article
data May and it's like you got your own
thing I don't that and so I've been on
multiple papers where there are
international collaborations with it and
so so I can say that I don't require
there to be immigration yeah you just
still collaborate the internet enables
that writes international conferences
enable it okay so so for Reid what do
you say if all the world is this fertile
landscape of communication then who
needs immigrants at that point there's
no question that you can do more
electronically than you ever have been
able to before but you know again comes
back to do we want the United States to
be the center the place where people
meet I remember after 9/11 there was a
period where there was similar kinds of
you know pauses and immigration slowed
down and increased vetting within
qualities you know all the things going
on a lot of scientific conferences were
cancelled that we're going to be held in
the United States and they held them in
Europe they held them in China now if we
you know if we keep doing this kind of
thing you know it's not the end of the
world but it certainly will mean that
the inner master cylinder of mass will
shift and frankly the Europeans are more
than happy to pick this up there's a
French presidential candidate just read
about this he said you know I just want
everybody to know anyone who finds that
there
having difficulty doing science in
America come to France we will give you
will roll out the red carpet for you and
that's the French let me tell you
something and that alone that's a way to
play a huge wake-up call to everyone in
this country that is like Ryan Gosling
talking to your wife at a cocktail party
and says listen if this eighth or
whatever if you have a good tired of
this jackass over here hi I'm Ryan
Gosling you're more than welcome to come
over and have coffee I had to tell you
something you're going to start treating
your woman a little differently I had a
similar earlier thought when I was
really read this news article about this
attempt to get ready for the next
asteroid so we can deflect it out of the
sky and by the time I got to the bottom
it was Russia organizing it asking who's
with them to make this happen that's it
and I felt like wait a minute I was just
so expecting that would be us inviting
others to participate right and I
realized that this if when you fade it's
not a cliff you just sort of slowly
desire and everyone else rises up and
they and they have conversations at
their table exactly whether or not
you're invited right and you know I love
the fact that you said when you fade
it's not a cliff it is indeed a slippery
slope and when people use that metaphor
they need to take in mind exactly what
the visual is it is a 45-degree angle
where you are slowly sliding jazz either
they're flying but it's not getting me
traction you just slide in the way so
that's what it is out of you out of you
you have to have one quick one if you
got a quick one okay here's here's a
quick one and this is for for read as
terrible things as things are could
better relations with Russia improve
science and space exploration yeah sure
look we should have good relations with
Russia we should have good relations
with China we should have good relations
with all these countries now the problem
is you know we have our nation ambition
when Russia invades another its neighbor
when it NX's parts of another country
you know something that basically hasn't
happened for decades and decades and it
contravenes international order you've
got to do something about it so there's
got to be a way and we by the way we
manage students even during the Cold War
to cooperate but also
certain rules of the road that matter
but I think that we must write their
work so I don't want you to go quickly
past that while we were still in cold
war with Russia we had the apollo-soyuz
joint space program and this was like
the early signs that maybe we can be
friends so just because there's
transgressive behavior in the world from
one country to another should that that
should not have to stop what might be
science or space collaborations I think
I think it's like it's all the more
reason to do it because you know you
want to build as many bonds as you can
between countries we don't work better
in isolation there's this wonderful book
by Matt Ridley about the height of human
beings manage just extraordinary rise
for you know from being just just
animals and the most important thing
points out is whenever we encountered
diversity we flourish
you know just even scientifically but as
human beings we the more we can
encounter the other the more we can
collaborate with people who think
differently look differently study
differently the end product is better
was who's the the wit of a hundred years
ago who said there's no greater pain to
the human spirit than the prospect of
coming up with a new idea I haven't
heard that one so I think we're going to
save this Neil aggress so what you say
is I think can be clearly demonstrated
but there's the the soul speaks
differently about who you want to hang
out with we want to create the the
homogeneous bubble but that's why you
want to get past your comfort zone and
into that into that area hard tightly
edited it's hard it's against it seems
to be against human nature to welcome in
the people who look different from you
and sound different from you and think
differently from you and have a
different religion or political idea
we've been part of the same tribes for
thousands and thousands you think about
it for most of human existence we grew
up we grew old and died one mile from
where we were born and now we're saying
all these people who come and in that
and grace the world as your tribe and
and even though those tribes are not
sending you their best they're sending
you criminals that are sending you
rapists oh [ __ ] it's time to end I think
that's
we're out of time jack talk about the
tribe thanks Chuck for co-hosting today
and thank you to our special guest CNN
what do they call you guys the anchors
anchor CNN anchor for Reid Zakaria you
all know is show GPS and adult miss it
I try to catch it every weekend when I
don't I catch it on CNN go so so four
reads thanks for joining us on this
special edition of Startalk which is the
inaugural version of cosmic queries
where we're trying to make America great
again I'm not trying to make America
smart again now we're trying to make
America smart again thank you that we're
trying to make America great again by
making America smart again all that this
has been Neil deGrasse Tyson on Startalk
and we're going to try to keep making
America smart again and until next time
keep looking up this is Startalk
[Music]
you
[Music]